tyler perry we already know him as a
big-time hollywood mogul but now
tyler has cemented his status as a
bonafide
billionaire
[Music]
you're you're living your best life
feeling pretty good you could say tyler
looks like
a billion bucks on the new cover of
forbes the magazine estimates the mogul
raked in more than 1.4 billion dollars
since 2005.
pretty inspiring considering tyler was
once homeless
i felt like for many years i was running
running running running running from
poverty
running running running now i'm just
like okay you're okay you can settle in
running for poverty man i'm telling you
that thing had was so traumatic for me
growing up in it i never wanted to even
think about it again
anybody who's been in it and lived it
this way you'll get it
you're never far away from enough from
it never far enough away
[Applause]
the high school dropout credits a chance
meeting with oprah that changed
everything oprah owning the oprah
winfrey show and understanding what that
meant
that was very very important to me
ownership changes
everything he's produced more than 1200
episodes of tv and
22 feature films including the medea
franchise and precious
his library of content is appraised at
320 million
every penny is tyler's and all because
early on
he insisted he retained the rights sure
you could own it they didn't think it
was going to be worth anything
the soon-to-be 51 year old owns his own
studio in atlanta worth an estimated 280
million
so this is the residence it even has its
own exact to scale replica of the white
house for his bet series the oval
according to forbes tyler owns a 60
million dollar stake in bet
he has 300 million in cash and
investments 40 million worth of homes
spread across four different states oh
and two
private jets to travel between them but
tyler also makes sure to give back to
the community
tyler perry paid for your grocery bill
today
are you kidding me i'll never forget
being in the grocery store
in atlanta trying to uh pay for some
food and couldn't pay for it there was a
woman behind me
who who gave them me the money to get
the food that i needed
that little act of kindness felt made me
feel like i could go on so
that's what those moments are about for
me just making people feel like they can
go on